those of us who live in this amazing
world of science and engineering have
got to pay more attention how to speak
to the public I am convinced one
approach is to embrace the value of the
visual that when we find better
vocabularies to express complicated
ideas there will be less confusion
across the globe about how to make
critical decisions that will affect our
health and our planet to educate all our
culture's on how to distinguish between
opinion and fact what approach is to
engage the public in our conversations
and we can do that creating honest
accessible compelling even beautiful
images of our research so that our work
will become less intimidating where your
mother or father will not be embarrassed
to ask questions about the images they
see of your work that's part of the
philosophy of this course in case you
didn't notice but so much of what we do
in our labs is difficult to explain so
first here's where I'd like to briefly
touch on the potential of visual
metaphors for example you've seen this
music box throughout this course I made
the image for our book no small matter
to engage the reader to think about the
language of computation a binary
language either on or off as this music
boxes clever system works it's either
one or zero take a good look and think
about it here's another one of these
metaphors along the same thinking of
explaining binary language these are
small drinking glasses viewed from above
the ones filled with red good Shiraz by
Joey represent one in this binary system
the empty glasses represents zero again
for the book no small matter the first
row across represents 12 in our everyday
number system if we add the
second row 22 the result in the third
row is 34 12 plus 22 equals 34 here's
another you've seen before we call it
etching with light suggesting how some
surfaces we work with in the laboratory
can be etched with various patterns and
here this cascade could suggest how the
flow of electrons change from one energy
state to another here's what I think
that works quite well these graduation
chairs are lined up basically to guide
parents where to sit it's a metaphor for
something called templated or guided
self assembly just as when DNA
replicates itself each of his strands
guides the distribution of basis for the
news strand here's one that I did love
making but maybe it doesn't quite work
enough I wanted to show the
counterintuitive pneus of quantum
mechanics now look at the shadow on the
right it doesn't make sense right in
fact that square shadow is impossible I
made it with software and so it is with
quantum mechanics so much of the quantum
phenomena simply just makes no sense at
all here's one from the Fermilab which I
thought was quite clever take a guess at
what this jelly bean jar is
metaphorically representing take a
moment and the fact that it's from
Fermilab is a big hand too so ok here is
that information in a pie chart of
course more quantitative we are seeing
the distribution of dark energy dark
matter and everything else in the
universe I think we pay more attention
to the jellybean jar do you what do you
think now none of these visual metaphors
work completely on their own first we
need some sort of text to help us look
and think about it and most important
all metaphors fall apart at some point
and that conversation of
they fall apart can be a powerful place
to talk about the science I encourage
you to start thinking about creating
metaphoric photographs that teach the
non-expert how to start thinking about
various scientific phenomena okay let's
switch gears and look at just a few
simpler ways to engage the public with
our images how about using some of your
new wonderful images of your work for
cards or announcements or posters could
be fun thinking about it the images you
will begin making after this course will
be pretty compelling I am sure of it why
not show them off outside the research
community all I suggest is to think
about ways to incorporate some of your
amazing new images in ways to excite the
public and who knows someday you might
even get an exhibit along the shaws
alizee what do you think